now as I said the NFL has got bigger
fish to fry right now because they're
trying to figure out whether or not
there's gonna be a football season and
at this point unfortunately no one knows
story that came out yesterday from
Andrew Marshawn of the New York Post and
this is something I've alluded to
already the idea that if college
football is not practical in the fall
there's been talk about maybe a February
to May season whatever the case may be
if they abandon Saturday's big cat the
NFL is considering that thing you love
in December that triple header last year
it was Texans Bucs
Bills Patriots Rams 49ers they're
considering playing games on Saturdays
to take up the space that would be
vacated by college football I think it
makes a ton of sense if Saturday's are
otherwise not going to have any sports
it makes sense
in principle Mike but now what look at
what you're gonna do so are you saying
there's gonna be three Saturday games
all season long is that the is that what
we're guessing if there's nothing here's
the thing that would be the maximum
right okay would be hang on the football
on maximum if the NFL wants to blow this
out - it's complete extent Friday night
game and three windows on Saturday just
like the three windows on Sunday that's
the maximum that they could do so what
that does is one it eliminates the red
zone madness that everyone loves - it
really makes it so that there are these
standalone games that we know when the
prime time games and the standalone
games are not good people don't people
will stop watching like to a point yeah
they'll complain about them they'll
watch them but they'll complain about
them
what are you sure though because there
are some games that I remember like
Monday night games Sunday night games
Thursday night games where the batch up
has not been good and it has shown a
little bit in the ratings and I think
when you when you stretch it all out and
you make the tea and you kind of dilute
where you have all these games a red
zone and you have your best games on
Sunday night Monday night it's going to
be a little bit harder to get people to
tune in especially people I do I am
convinced that in America there are
there are certain people that are
college
football fans only NFL fans only so when
you stretch it out and you say you got
to watch Saturday and Sunday will people
still be tuning in at the same numbers I
think they'll obviously be tuning in
that's not my point
I don't think it's gonna be apples to
apples where you can say oh these are
our Sunday numbers we'll just put a
couple games Saturday they'll be exactly
the same but here's the thing if we get
to the point where there's no college
football if we are still in a situation
where you can't play that sport and
maybe can't play other sports like what
else are we gonna do look last week with
people sitting in their basements doing
zoom appearances and in the ratings were
higher than ever because what the hell
else do we have I think that's what it
comes down to projecting how many people
will consume the content on Saturday
when there's no college football all
those thousands of people who would be a
college football games are a home what
are they doing and there's no other
sports on on Saturday here's NFL games
that we can watch and I come you'll be
bad football there will be bad football
and it will be in bright lights when it
is bad and people will complain and just
get ready for that I listen I want more
football I'll take all the footballers
especially in the world you just
described where there's nothing else
going on but just get ready for it
because when you stretch out the games
and you start having these standalone
games you lose the red zone the witching
hour it will feel very different if the
choices are Jacksonville Miami or cat
cave derby 135 I'm taking Jacksonville
Miami sorry afraid but one other thing
I'm gonna write about this at Pro
Football Talk calm today shameless plug
there are some business issues that I
think would complicate this for the NFL
because you'd be taking games away from
Sunday and diluting that product for the
network's
and then you're you're doing this on
Saturday because you want to make more
money
how are the networks going to come up
with more money they're just not going
to double the rights fees for this year
at a time when the advertising dollars
drawing I'm drying up so there's a lot
of issues that could make this
unattractive for the NFL from a business
standpoint even though Saturday may be
wide open waiting for someone to drop
football into those windows that
otherwise would have the college version
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports